Donald Trump claims he will be arrested
tomorrow will he I don't know is Trump
lying maybe is Trump confused possibly
often is the case but if Trump is
indicted if Trump is arrested what will
be the reaction from magas well here are
the five reactions I expect number one
we've already seen this one
investigators already resigned because
there was no case so you know that this
case is bogus wrong
didn't happen we covered this at the
time
the truth is that investigators resigned
because they came to believe even though
we are finding evidence against Trump we
don't believe there's any real
willingness to indict him so we're
wasting our time the right Wingers are
defending Trump by saying investigators
resigned because there was no evidence
the truth is investigators resigned
because there was evidence but they
thought it was all for nothing because
nobody would actually indict Trump
if Trump is indicted they will have been
wrong but it is a lie that is being told
that's reaction number one the
investigators already decided there was
no case no they did not number two and
they're already saying this the focus
really should be on Hunter Biden and
there's a few different versions of this
defense and one is they are arresting
Trump
to distract from Hunter Biden makes no
sense whatsoever
the the legal the the bodies that are
investigating Hunter Biden uh are not
are are not necessarily the ones that
would be indicting Trump or arresting
Trump complete fabrication no evidence
whatsoever response number three from
the magas Democrats are doing this
because Trump is surging against Biden
in the 2024 polls ER wrong we actually
need only look at the polling to figure
this out and consistently Ron DeSantis
is stronger against Biden than is Trump
so the facts conflict we have a new uh
Emerson College poll highly rated
pollster which says Biden is losing to
DeSantis but leading Trump well that
doesn't really go with what Trump is
claiming we have a um we have a
Quinnipiac University poll which finds
that Biden leads DeSantis by only one
but leads Trump by four
so this is another claim that they are
making Democrats are doing this because
Trump is getting so strong in the
polling they need to do something to
hurt him no in fact it is DeSantis who
is stronger in the polling number four
they will say and they already did this
over the weekend on Newsmax and
elsewhere this is evidence of the
two-tier justice system one system of
justice for republicans and one system
of justice for Democrats ER wrong there
is a two-tier justice system but it is
that for the rich who can negotiate
their surrenders without having to be
handcuffed and all these things and then
everybody else we have a two-tier
justice system but it is not Republicans
and Democrats and then lastly number
five defense is these charges related to
the Stormy Daniels hush money are very
very weak I actually agree with that
defense My Hope Is as I said in the last
segment that this is just the beginning
and that the levy will break with these
charges if indeed they are coming we
don't know that for sure
and that then other prosecutors
federally maybe in Georgia which I
believe is actually the strongest case
in Georgia other charges will come
forward and that this will only be the
beginning but I agree actually with the
magas the Stormy Daniels situation is
not the strongest set of facts
for an arrest and indictment against
Donald Trump so those are the five
defenses that I expect many of which
inversions we are already seeing let's
take a quick break and after the break
we will talk about some of the other
aspects of this they're talking about
George Soros or I should say George
shorosh as they often I don't know why
the the people who really don't like
George Soros seem unable to say his last
name correctly and so many other things
stay with us on what could be the eve of
an historic day
of a historic day of both potentially on
the David Pacman show youtube.com slash
the David Pacman show make sure you're
subscribed folks
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 percent
with the code pacman10 at checkout out
just remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below